hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday January 8th 2018 that's a
lot of age dude I should go get a
[ __ ] scratch ticket and play nothing
but eight do my number came in he hit it
for [ __ ] seven and a quarter we got
to go down to [ __ ] or the [ __ ]
those casinos down there Jesus Christ I
perform at him gonna go down I'm a he
and son dude hit the [ __ ] blackjack
table split aces kid what I'm playing
with house money how are you how was
your first weekend of the year did you
did you enjoy it
there's only 51 left or four left if you
listen to people who are [ __ ]
freaking out about global warming I mean
you know I'm not saying that I it
doesn't concern me but I just kind of
take it day to day I look out the window
right there's no zombies I can turn on
the faucet there's still water okay all
right you got look for the zombies first
I like the old zombies you know what I
mean the ones that walked real slow you
had a [ __ ] chance as opposed to now
they're like running around I'll write
it up write it up it's right there on
the [ __ ] juice all these zombies need
to be tested they got to get it out of
the [ __ ] league all right all those
kills that all those other zombies have
that's why like zombies are killing so
many people now you know I mean of
course you don't you don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm talking about neither do i all
right if you new to my podcast how are
you get ready to listen to some of the
dumbest [ __ ] you're gonna hear for you
know for like another 58 minutes I think
yeah good call a minute 52 minute 52
into the podcast I'm gonna [ __ ] Pat
myself on the back that's the back of my
head that's why it was [ __ ] sounded
like you know
um my [ __ ] wedding ring you know
sucks my winter wedding ring you got
this little piece of metal on your hand
you hit yourself you know it's like a
constant [ __ ] why can't it's like a
painful reminder oh that's right I'm
married you know fly goes onto your face
you whack yourself right in the face you
already slap yourself in the face and
then your wedding ring like catches like
your brow you don't like ah [ __ ] and
right after that happens your wife goes
asking if you could do me a favor when
that come from
I did the smartest thing tonight right
me and my wife right my wife we had this
you know every once in a while you got a
clean house right and be like all right
let's go with a kid can't hear us let's
just sit down and we're gonna talk about
what we've been doing over the last
whatever month six months decade
depending on how long it's been since
you've had those talks right having a
talk in in in a relationship is like
[ __ ] the NDA year when you have to do
your taxes and you didn't organize
anything in you got any years with the
[ __ ] receipts all sticking out all
over the place and you just keep putting
it off and putting it off you know what
I mean
the next thing you know the box is
[ __ ] another box down the street
right so we try to air it out so we went
out all right got some chicken wings and
we just [ __ ] it I think we were just
gonna go out to hang we knew that we
needed to hang out like we got to hang
out right the kids taking a lot of our
us time we need to go [ __ ] hang us so
we go hang out and then just all this
[ __ ] came up all right and one of the
things that I was doing is I was ruining
television for her cuz I I don't shut up
when I watch TV i imitate people I make
fun of them and when the other person is
in the room and they want to watch the
show evidently it's really annoying
of course it's annoying so and if she's
watching reality TV like I never shut up
because it's just
I don't know oh yeah so I've been trying
not you know she's watching something
with that we both enjoy like O's ACK you
know or the black mirror they all got
busted they got the arse in there all
the shows that we like Twilight Zone all
of that [ __ ] if we watch a [ __ ] like
that I shut up alright but if it's
anything else I don't shut the [ __ ] up
so if she's watching like reality shows
so tonight she was watching the Golden
Globes alright
and I know right there I can't watch
that show with her because she's gonna
get mad at me so I just wanted to watch
Seth's monologue
I always watch the comic cause it's such
a it's such a [ __ ] crazy gig right to
come out there you're doing all brand
new [ __ ] and like sitting right in the
front row like two feet away is [ __ ]
Oprah Winfrey and you know Samuel Jack
said it will default people are there
that it's like the whole MOOC the whole
everything you're watching at home on TV
the television shows movies all of a
sudden it turns around and looks at you
well you you go out there with a new
[ __ ] ten minutes so whatever the hell
it is they do so I'm watching that
Seth is [ __ ] killing and I and I Lee
the first time I talked was at some
point when I saw Oprah was sitting there
I leaned up ago Kim actually doing your
jokes and Oprah is like right there she
was like and and I was like oh [ __ ]
alright and I just did me like I'm gonna
shut up and then the awards show started
and the smartest thing I did is I just I
I pretended I had to go do something and
I just sort of got up and I walked out
so I wouldn't I wouldn't do the rest of
it I wouldn't do the rest I wouldn't
ruin the [ __ ] chauffeur and you guess
what we're not in a fight right now
it's unbelievable you know and she would
just I just stayed in the kitchen I made
some waffles I'm one of those breakfast
for dinner kind of guys you know that's
how I do it that's my swagger that's
that's that's the marble man that I
haven't be
I just realized the second I said that
that's like some [ __ ] you say when
you're trying to be interesting on a
date or if you're too dumb to know
you're not interesting you would say
something I first of all I want to thank
everyone who's still listening this the
fact that I said I'm a breakfast for
dinner kind of guy all right what I
should have said was I like having
breakfast for dinner sometimes but I
sent him a breakfast for dinner kind of
guy once you say kind of guy you should
be legally required to do the double
[ __ ] pistol shot with you you fingers
I'm that kind of guy bang-bang site of
[ __ ] sausage so I was out there
making waffles and she yelled out she
goes Sammy one Sammy one Sam Rockwell
one so I you know obviously loves Sam
and he did something that's really hard
to do he had a great speech and and then
you know I was watching a little bit
more and I felt all these things that I
was going to say so I just walked out I
walked up before I said something stupid
you know if you tux is all black you're
not a rapist welcome to the Golden
Globes like I would have been doing [ __ ]
like that
do you realize you could be an absolute
[ __ ] monster okay but if you wore an
all-black tuxedo like no everyone would
be looking at you like you were
progressive that's why I'd you know I
understand why it's done because it's a
show of strength and everybody's like
yes this is obviously something that you
know needs to stop yada yada yada and a
bunch of other obvious [ __ ] but it also
creates this thing with you could just
walk in and no one's gonna [ __ ] with you
because you're wearing the right uniform
that's why I don't like all of that
political correctness stuff is because
you create a road map for people to just
get across the river because they know
what to say what not to say when they're
in public and everything oh he said
Native American he said my mom
well obviously and he has an all black
tuxedo he must be a good person all
right now all of this it's just [ __ ]
that no one wants to [ __ ] hear when
they're trying to watch so I ran in I
saw Sam Rockwell when I heard Carol
Burnett was there I ran and I saw that
and when I heard Roseanne Barr and John
Goodman were on I I ran and I watched
that you know and I went out I self
something else I said Jennifer Aniston
although she was there with uh uh Carol
Burnett how [ __ ] great does she look
telling you man she does not aged at all
her and [ __ ] Howie long I said the
exact same that's kind of weird right I
say the exact same thing myself I want
today when I was watching the playoffs I
think if he [ __ ] looks unbelievable
guy just doesn't he has not lost one
hair on top of his head
Ivan even have that haircut since I was
like 15 anyways
I [ __ ] watch so much goddamn sports
this weekend all right I did do a little
duolingo trying to get back into the
hole trying to I have to become
bilingual and I have to learn how to
speak French because that's such a
snooty [ __ ] language I'm such a dope
how hilarious would it be that's what
keeps me going
alright not respect for the culture not
trying to improve myself just how
[ __ ] funny it would be if I was
completely fluent in French and like
really good at it I could speak the
slang but the I wouldn't have an accent
you know let me just think of how much
dumb [ __ ] I've said right now and yet
all of a sudden out of nowhere I could
just start speaking perfect I could go
to Paris and no one would turn their
[ __ ] nose up at me oh the opportunity
I'm telling you I want to do that
because I want to go there and I want to
act like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I mean I don't have to act I'm just I'd
ramp it up you know and then just listen
to hear what they would say and I would
just I would ten days of just laugh at
my [ __ ] balls off and then ruining it
for all you guys who go over there if
you're from here anyways so I
I had the Peach Bowl taped recorded
saved in [ __ ] digital space whatever
the [ __ ] you kids say and I was meaning
to watch it because I came home from the
Rose Bowl and I saw I was like holy [ __ ]
Central Florida won so I actually put it
on in my wife was six this weekend you
know everybody got the bug everybody got
the stomach fool I haven't got it yet
okay I take these little chewables all
right
and I I take immense what the [ __ ] do
you call it immense vitamin whether they
call those things men's daily or some
[ __ ] I never take him I take him when I
start to feel sick and I knew everybody
was getting sick around me so I just
started [ __ ] just chowing those
things down right and I've been able to
hold it off and last night I actually
slept in a different room you know I
mean I love my wife but you know I'm not
gonna stop puking and [ __ ] and you don't
know anything
unnecessarily I wouldn't put her through
that right I mean Jesus Christ for
better for worse and then there's like
common sense that my wife's cool as hell
so she was like yeah get out of here get
out of here so I left you know what's
weird is if you ever just like sweetie
when I sleep in a different room I sleep
on the opposite side of the bed so when
I wake up and I get a sense that the
edge of the bed is on the wrong side and
I'm not on the road you know it freaks
me out like where the [ __ ] am I did I
get arrested for a murder I didn't
commit and then I open my eyes and my
all [ __ ] no I'm just sleeping in a
different room in my own house that's
cool
um so anyway so I watched the [ __ ]
Peach Bowl and I watched Central Florida
man what a [ __ ] game what a game in
Central Florida huh right this is long
overdue Congrats in that I hope they say
his name - a'queen griffin the
linebacker on the team the guy's got one
hand he's got one hand and he was
dominating dominating Auburn who I swear
to god half of there
guys look like they had like 40 pounds
on whoever they were lining up against
and I love Auburn I love Auburn I love
watching a beat Alabama you know I love
seeing that [ __ ] it's just fun it's fun
to see you know cuz Alabama is supposed
to win so Auburn was supposed to win
that one so I mean how do you not root
for Central Florida Central Florida it I
went to that campus right did I go to
the Central Florida I don't think I did
I went to the other one where the game
was at the war in the for the one that's
in Orlando I went to that one and I just
went in and I looked at the campus I was
like yeah I I could have got accepted
here I could have gone to this [ __ ]
school like their campus is in the
middle of like a rotary like there's a
big roundabout and they just but it's
like they had a big roundabout and then
they they stuck a school right in the
middle of it so I had to root for him
because I loved that game so much you
know so you got a love an underdog so
congratulations to them and what else
then I watched all of the playoff games
playoffs except yet no I can't say that
I watched two of the games today and I
missed you don't put the Kansas City
game on right at the end and because my
brother text me he said was talking
about Sean mcdonoughs voice when it
cracked I can't believe the level of
[ __ ] the guy got for that it was a great
call it just was it just wasn't a
touchdown then everybody who sues
[ __ ] miserable 'he's got to trash the
guy i wish something as exciting as that
happened every game just to hear him
lose his [ __ ] all i heard was a guy that
loves the game and [ __ ] loves his job
everybody hear his voice quick i don't
know my voice cracks when i get excited
you know anyways so everybody's jumping
all over uh andy reid you know giving
him [ __ ] for [ __ ] i don't know i
don't you know what the hell happened i
have no idea i know that they're big
[ __ ] tight end the potato sack race
guy i know we took a shot to the head so
he wasn't in the game obviously that
would change i'm the bill you were
literally gonna break down a game he
didn't
yeah probably probably you know you know
loves to say you know what the guy can't
get it done I can't get it done and he
Radia like I can't get it done you know
people love to say that kind of [ __ ]
people can't get it done in their own
lives you know I mean I can't get it
done nobody can get it done in Kansas
City nobody's got it done in Kansas City
since [ __ ] Hank Stram all right he's
gone to a [ __ ] franchise that is a
perennial [ __ ] loser and he came from
another one Philadelphia
that's a perennial [ __ ] loser all
right Kansas City won a Superbowl in
1970 the [ __ ] Eagles won in 1960
anybody can do the Phil Jackson thing
and [ __ ] go jump on the goddamn
Lakers when they guy already got Kobe
Bryant and Shaq Andy Reid likes a
challenge I'm going to the most
miserable [ __ ] sports city in the
world Philadelphia they he went there
before the Phillies won all right when
it was a [ __ ] drought where they'd
won in 1980 you know what I mean
so in defense of that guy is everybody
[ __ ] all over them like they would
have known how to run the clock or
whatever the [ __ ] they given him [ __ ]
about that guy he's taking on two huge
[ __ ] challenges the Philadelphia
Eagles and the Kansas City Chiefs all
right so there's my take on it having
not watched the game you see that you
see what happens when you just you find
an angle and you just go off on it it
actually sounded for half a second like
I knew what I was talking about right
actually you know why I didn't see the
game the real reason I didn't see the
game wasn't because my wife was sick the
real reason why is because I was busy
looking at game Phil Phil I was busy
looking at game film getting ready to
you know I had to coach some kids Oh
buffalo against his team the Jag was one
more person sends me a goddamn photo
going is it me or you looked just like
this guy it's
dude that joke was made like a year ago
like if you guys really want to just
[ __ ] annoy me just keep sending me
that like and you got to deliver it like
it's the first time you know I should
have done I should have started
retweeting all of them I maybe that's
why I didn't do it I thought I already
retweeted them to be like that this joke
has been made let's can we build on it
I'm not saying don't make the joke but
you got it knock knock who's there
banana and then who knock knock who's
there banana banana who I get it where
the hell am I all right Jags beat the
[ __ ] bills
oh that's right I watch that that's the
first game I watched I missed the
Atlanta Falcons playing the Rams and I
think like a lot of people I forgot that
Atlanta won the first 58 minutes of last
year's Superbowl and then what was great
was they completely [ __ ] up their
regular season to the point nobody was
talking about him but they made the
playoffs so now our playoff since I and
I everybody's zero and zero to start and
they got all that experience in last
year last year right I don't know what
the [ __ ] do they play next week they go
to Philly
they go to Philly and Philly was all
lined up to go and what happens huh
Carson Wentz gets his [ __ ] knee
[ __ ] up for the rest of the season
because it's Philly okay and I'm not
[ __ ] not Philly any Eagle fan will tell
you this the second you put that [ __ ]
helmet on somebody's got to break that
curse man do you think it's gonna be
Nick Foles huh
does his last name sound too much like
Follies the Nick Foles Follies if he
[ __ ] blows this game I'm telling you
right now he's gonna be starting one of
those Ice Capades he'll be like the guy
with the top hat bringing out a bunch of
old Eagles on ice skates that never won
Super Bowls I'm trying to figure out who
I'm gonna root for this obviously I'm
rooting for the Patriots but who else do
I like you know I actually like the
Saints what a great game that was now
that game I saw
against the [ __ ] Panthers a lot of
drops critical drops by the Panthers the
first step you know what I think it's
gonna happen I think drew brees Drew
Brees the underrated Drew Brees he's
like third all-time passing nobody talks
about him you don't I mean you know why
he's just a regular looking guy you know
he's a little taller than Doug Flutie
okay he's a little shyer than [ __ ]
Brett Favre and he's not as good-looking
as Tom Brady you know and he's down
there in New Orleans and nobody's paying
attention nobody's [ __ ] paying
attention and meanwhile the guys out
there killing it he's got a Super Bowl
ring so now he's going to Minnesota to
face some guy named Case Keenum who
people are saying he's in the running
I'll be the only play of the league he
is you think Drew Brees is afraid of it
I don't think he is
I'm it isn't my prediction for next week
knowing nothing about the Minnesota
Vikings okay
I say Drew Brees goes into Minnesota
okay and when he leaves it's gonna be a
bunch of people crying at the Mall of
America I think the state's going and
they [ __ ] beat Minnesota you know
buddy of mine was going I can't believe
Minnesota built another dome they're
like a cold City team that's like a
great advantage and now Drew Brees is
gonna go in and play in a dome he's
gonna be at home and I was just like why
did they make a dome and I was like
that's what I was thinking but we're old
guys and I think that you know the NFL's
done with us you know they're now trying
to move on to the Millennials and you
got to build the dome because
Millennials don't like to go outside
right so if you can just get them to an
uber they'll get to the game and then
you look look you're back inside again
you're back inside this big TV screens
you can stare at those instead of watch
the game but you can sit here and say
you you you are at what you watched on a
TV
all right the Patriots are playing the
Titans we'll see we'll see how that one
goes you never know and who do the
Steelers got the Steelers got the
[ __ ] uh they got the Jags right
the Steelers got the Jags I'm kind of
happy both those teams one of them's
gonna knock the other guy off although I
am NOT excited you know if we get past
the Titans I am NOT excited to play the
Steelers again because they already beat
us once this year but unfortunately we
were given the victory over that whole
[ __ ] I mean it's a good thing
because we never get in the home field
but I always think the team that loses
has the advantage the second time around
however however I just think Bill
Belichick is such a superior coach by
the way you know I really have to
address this stupid [ __ ] about Bill
Belichick that he's gonna leave the
Patriots over a [ __ ] personal trainer
I sometimes I just think that the
[ __ ] media just has it out for the
[ __ ] Patriots I just don't understand
never seen such a big bunch of [ __ ] made
out of nothing and here's the thing if
he's [ __ ] going bad if Belichick ever
went back to the Giants who gives a [ __ ]
he's not ours he started with the Giants
okay we didn't he started with like the
[ __ ] Lions or something but he
started with the Giants okay that's
where he got his first ring then he went
over to the goddamn Jets right the man
goes over to the [ __ ] Jets and know
he went to Cleveland before that and
they fired him typical Cleveland move he
goes over to the Jets he who's got to be
the Jets coach it was right there and
then he just wanted to get out from
underneath Bill Parcells and he left so
I it wouldn't be a defection out of
Boston it would be a return home we
[ __ ] stole that guy in 1999 we've
gone to seven Super Bowls one five maybe
that's why we never beat the Giants that
was the football gods go a bill you
never should have left actually should
have left you know what I mean
that was like when he stepped out from
Bill Parcells shadow became the [ __ ]
legend that he is now but anyway it's
the end of the [ __ ] day I don't give
a [ __ ] about Tom Brady's personal
trainer I don't give a [ __ ] who the [ __ ]
would break up the goddamn band over
that is beyond me
am I really supposed to think that
that's a real [ __ ] thing that would
shock me not if he left it would just
shock me if it was over that but you
know Bill Parcells left over Terry Glenn
rest in peace you know I'll never quite
forgive that guy for telling the [ __ ]
team that he wasn't coming back the next
year before we played the Packers in
their Super Bowl and uh actually has
that ever even been confirmed somebody
just told me he did that all right I'd
like to apologize to Bill Parcells what
the [ __ ] am I talking about here she
listening to as a man who did nothing
but this weekend that's what you're
doing okay that's why you're probably
listening cuz you probably did it too
all right
he's one of the douchiest things I
haven't done it yet but I'm gonna do it
and I feel like I have to admit to it
before I do it okay anybody in in
Ireland wait I got to make sure that's
the right country who makes shepherd's
pie you know I mean there's like all
these those [ __ ] pies over there I
love all of them because I got all that
blood in me English Irish Scottish so
any sort of those [ __ ] meat pies I
like that [ __ ] all right shepherd's pie
or Ridge in shepherd's pie was invented
by Shane is so shepherd shepherd's pie
or cottage pie is a meat pie
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba place of origin the
United Kingdom oh all right because
there's no sheep in Ireland is that what
it is I always forget that in Ireland
they make it they make a different one
right shepherd's pie our cards for Hyper
Papa Bob father do you think you can
history this is gonna be boring as [ __ ]
in early cookbooks the dish was a means
of using leftover roasted meat of any
kind and a pie dish was
lined with mashed potatoes as well as
having a mashed potato crust on top as
they built the wall around it back then
where did it come from like that I can't
find it so I can't so I just yelled at
my computer I don't give a [ __ ] you know
that's it right there that's why I
didn't do well in school I look it up
and I high up again I got I got that
clock in my head like a quarterback you
know you got the clock before I just
throw it out of Bounce
I don't care now now I'm not gonna learn
it I'll [ __ ] make it up on the next
question and that's why I got like a 390
combined on my SATs I did and I took a
prep course and I actually I actually I
studied did I bring I don't think I
break broke 400 I know whatever you do
do it give you like 350 I know I know
anyways I'm gonna make a shepherd's pie
with cauliflower mashed potatoes I just
have to pause here as everybody's gone
oh yeah cuz this gluten-free diet that
I'm doing I'm kind of half-ass doing it
but just half-assed doing it I I don't
have to work out it's [ __ ] great
telling you man if you lay off the
gluten I remember thinking what the [ __ ]
is gluten then they told me what it's
everything that it's in and I'm like oh
so like all the good foods all the foods
I love I've just been laying off the old
glute they're gluten free if you ever
saw my flat ass you'd be surprised
sorry bad joke yeah so I'm gonna make it
with cauliflower because I'm not allowed
to eat potatoes
I'm sorry people I've been out here too
long you know I've been 10 years out
here out here in Hollywood and I've
become a gluten-free douche I'm not
really because I got these brioche buns
that I bought for the hot dogs at the
Rose Bowl it was the only thing I [ __ ]
up I forgot to not only bring hot dogs I
forgot to buy them so I have all of
these brioche buns it's like I'm not
gonna throw them out so I went out I
brought some hot dogs so I'm kind of
full of sodium and gluten at this point
anyways so I'm gonna make shepherd's pie
with mashed potatoes and I'm not putting
this lits one recipe I saw they had corn
in it and I was like I wouldn't [ __ ] it
why would you do that it's all about the
piece you got the lamb in there right
you got a little bit of onion minced
that up a couple other [ __ ] salt and
pepper whatever there else you put in
there and then didn't you get the piece
[ __ ] corn it's an imposter it doesn't
have the guts of a pea that's why it's
yellow it's a little yellow [ __ ]
cowardly [ __ ] sort of vegetable it's
not a fruit is it I don't know it's not
something I do I make your shepherd's
pie with [ __ ] mashed potatoes
cauliflower mashed potatoes and actually
really like cauliflower mashed potatoes
I don't like cauliflower but if you're
gonna throw a bunch of butter on it I
mean how is it not gonna taste good you
know the only thing I really don't like
is that [ __ ] what is that [ __ ] they
were putting in everything for a while
what they [ __ ] it was it being with that
tea didn't it truffle oil
I mean one time we went out and there
was mashed potatoes and they had truffle
oil in it no no I'm sorry had macaroni
and cheese and they put truffle oil and
why would you do that you don't need to
it's pasta with cheese [ __ ] off you know
truffle oil for a while was like the
[ __ ] Hari Krishna of ingredients you
know yeah a little B don't want any [ __ ]
out of here leave me alone
and I and the waiter or the waitress or
is there an is there I can't believe no
one's been offended by that yet waiter
in waitress Emily all waiters is there a
[ __ ] gender gender-neutral [ __ ]
term we can come with up with that
a wait attendant well that's gonna get
someone a body image the [ __ ] person
who gives you your food who would rather
be doing a different job for better
money there is that a good description
was that genderless told me that there
was only a little bit of truffle there's
just a hint of it it's just a hint
there's just a - I was like all right
and I ordered it and it just it sucked
truffle oil overpowers every [ __ ]
thing it's like a comic that's on off
stage like a [ __ ] lampshade over its
goddamn head I hate truffle oil I don't
even know what it is should I look that
up and [ __ ] isn't it from like a
mushroom or something truffle oil this
is why the internet makes people less
funny because back in the day he just
had no idea and he just guessed and then
there was always somebody in the room
with a big enough [ __ ] ego to just
definitively give you an answer even
though they didn't know truffle oil is a
modern culinary ingredient used to
impart the flavor and aroma of truffles
to a dish and right now we're looking up
truffles my truffle is a fruiting body
of subterranean it's come set fungus
[ __ ] is that right now I'm looking up
scum set a scum set is a division or a
phylum of the kingdom of Fuji Bunji all
right what's a phylum in biology of
phylum is a level of classification or a
taxonomic rank
biological classification a taxonomical
rank see what st. this is why don't look
up [ __ ] I'm too dumb to understand the
[ __ ] definition it's just it just
keeps going it's like a Hummel by the
time you get down and you don't even
know what the [ __ ] you were asking the
question it's like you ever going like
like I can't say that you know what I
mean some of these these streaming sites
right and you're [ __ ] I'm gonna watch
that watch that not watch it was another
thing I was gonna watch alright anyway
so what am I read a little bit
advertising Shelley shall I read a
little bit of advertising oh look who's
back
endo Chi Indochina
talk about how every man looks better in
a suit yes they do especially if it's an
all-black suit at the Golden Globes so
we know that you're progressive okay we
know that you're a progressive person
you're not wearing that suit - hopefully
ward off any investigation on your cell
phone all right
endo Chi you know it's the largest
custom apparel company they make suits
and shirts I know those words in French
costume she's made to your exact
measurements for a great fit guys love
the wide selection of high quality
fabrics and the option to personalize
all the details including the lapel
jacket lining monogram and much more
that's actually cool you can customize
it
alright here's how it works pick your
fabric choose your customizations submit
your measurements place your order and
wait for it to arrive in three weeks or
less is it any wonder why people are so
fat now this is incredible
you can shoot back in the day if you
wanted to have something made you had to
go down and talk to Jimmy the gent he'd
be like yeah I keep going it's right
there
you almost got whacked trying to get
your own personal C's [ __ ]
Millennials they don't ought to work for
anything you can shop online and end
okey-doke calm or visit any of their
showrooms across North America this week
my listeners can get any premium
indochina suit for just three hundred
and fifty nine dollars a custom suit
people for three and a fifty nine bucks
in indochina calm when entering BER at
the checkup that's i ND o CH i n o endo
like Indonesia or in do go in that door
what do you want to do I and do I always
assume people just as dumb as me and
then you know how to spell China
take off the a and put on a no
indo-china [ __ ] am i that's all over 50%
off the race regular price for a premium
made-to-measure suit plus shipping is
absolutely [ __ ] free
that's Indo Chino calm promo code bar
for any premium suit for just three
hundred fifty nine dollars plus shipping
even if you're the size of Andy Reid Wow
didn't he get enough [ __ ] get a big red
suit you know with the game clock and
the lapel all right zip ah look who's
back goes through a simple crudo post
your job to over 100 post your job don't
100 of the web's leading job boards with
just one click oh that's awesome
then zip recruiter actually looks for
the most qualified candidates and
invites them to apply they even review
every application to identify the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match that's why zip is different unlike
other hiring sites yep recruiter doesn't
depend on the right candidates finding
you it finds them no wonder 80% of
employees who post on zip
you get a quality candidate through the
site in just one day zip recruit at the
smart way to hire find out today why is
it has been used by businesses of all
sizes and industries to find the most
qualified job candidates with the
immediate results and right now my
listeners can post jobs on Sep recruiter
for free that's right free just go to
zip recruit comm / / that zip recruiters
out comm / / one more time / / alright
how many more [ __ ] beats Jesus - more
Dollar Shave Club dude dude come on in
where you been Dollar Shave Club at the
store at this store there go down to the
[ __ ] pack you get me a 12 a natty
light that there's still one there are
too many options and you can't tell the
difference between any of them then if
you have any questions
the clerk usually doesn't know what the
[ __ ] they're talking about either or you
can't really help you since they're
they're not experts on the products and
usually you know there's just one person
working the register and there's
somebody else running around getting ice
cream for old people there's nobody
there's nobody there you don't I mean I
love when the old people go into the
[ __ ] pharmacy to get their ice cream
you know that's how they live off Social
Security you know you make tough
decisions like that all of us running
around going to these gourmet [ __ ]
places they go to the pharmacy ice cream
is ice cream it all gives you a headache
if you eat it fast enough Dollar Shave
Club makes it easy and convenient for
you to upgrade to your shave upgrade
your shave and your bathroom I need to
remodel your bathroom Jesus now you
don't have to set foot in the store to
get a high-quality shave and grooming
products Dollar Shave Club delivers them
right to your door once again making
people fatter but goddamn it you're
gonna look good we have a nice smooth
[ __ ] face if you're sick of the
nonsense at the store now's the time to
try out Dollar Shave Club for a limited
time Dollar Shave Club is basically
giving away their [ __ ] shower shave
starter kits to new members for only $5
this starter set features their
exclusive
razor and three trial sized versions of
their most popular products that help
you stay so fresh and so clean in your
first box you will receive their shave
body wash and one white cherry butt
wipes you will also receive their
executive razor which includes their
premium weighty handle and a full casket
of charges cartridges sorry after the
first box replacement cartridges are
sent for only a few bucks a month this
offer is exclusively available at
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's Dollar
Shave Club com / / Dollar Shave club's
high quality products will have you
covered from face cheeks to butt cheeks
there's no better time to try the club
and lastly but certainly not least Lee
the headliner always bringing up the
rear
loyal no matter what I've ever said
they've always stuck with me god bless
them you know you lava give you some
stamps calm everybody there's a new
year's resolution you can actually keep
add stamps calm to your business and
save a ton of time and money this year
share your experience with House stamps
calm has helped you maximize I'm gonna
start speaking in a different when they
try to tell me what to do in these
things bill if you could share your
experience with the House stamps.com is
help you maximize time and money
oh geez the amount of time I used to
waste you know I used to walk backwards
to the uphill to the [ __ ] post office
you know with my wallet hanging out of
the back of my pants through a bad
neighborhood you know but now with
stamps calm they save me time and money
almost everything you can do at the post
office you can do right from your desk
plus stamps commas postage discount she
yeah try to think what else you couldn't
do I guess you couldn't check out the
girls ass in front of you at the post
it's your house but you know what if you
stick your scale close enough to the
window you can check out you name not to
mention it's a fraction of the cost of
those super expensive postage meters
stamps calm will send you a digital
scale that automatically calculates the
exact postage you will never overpay or
under pay for postage again and right
now you too can enjoy stamps calm sir
with a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus postage and a
digital scale ready for a happy new year
go to stamps come click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in Burke that stamps.com enter
ber all right and when done we're done
with the reads for the week if you might
notice you might have noticed that I am
in a little more of a perkier mood I am
in a great move because guess guess what
guess what guess what guess what I
finally made a breakthrough in my rehab
of this [ __ ] lingering rotator cuff
injury you know sorry I don't you know
if its cup or cuff I think it's cuff I
always forget I think I said cup for
most of my life let's go back to wrote
Wikipedia wrote a wrote a tour oh it's
cuff it's not cup in anatomy the rotator
cuff is a group of muscles and their
tendons that act to stabilize the
shoulder yeah that's the problem because
when they [ __ ] don't the shoulder
kind of comes out of the socket maybe I
don't know the four muscles of the
rotator cuff are are over half of the
seven scapula Emil muscles scapular
muscles are a group of seven muscles
that connect to the humerus the humerus
to the scapula
there are amongst the muscles that act
on the glial Jay what the [ __ ] is that
the shoulder joint
oh that's a shoulder joint the Glenn o
humbrol joint out who gives a [ __ ]
anyways my shoulders been bugging me so
like I didn't understand I don't
understand out a rehab I like when I
felt pain I stopped I didn't understand
that you had to kind of go into it a
little bit like you skimming the
frosting off right or if you're making
steel cut oats you know that awful gluey
[ __ ] on top you just skim that off he
kind of got to do that with the pain so
this person told me this great exercise
we wear I just I laid
on my back and then put my arm like if I
was standing up I would be pointing
straight ahead but when you lay down
you're backing out pointing at the
ceiling okay I'm not saying put your arm
up over your [ __ ] head just point
straight up and just start making little
circles you know a bunch clockwise a
bunch of counterclockwise and then you
just gradually increase slowly as [ __ ]
the circumference of them and when you
start to feel the top layer of pain you
know that's where you stop but you but
when you when I was going how I've been
doing it when I go around into this
circle is I kind of stay at an
acceptable level of confronting the pain
and I swear to god I've been doing that
for like the lit just like since
Thursday and I've gotten like 30%
increase I would say in my range of
motion and I feel like I can get this
thing you know I'm not saying
re-strengthen it but I think I can get
it all back by the end of the [ __ ] my
thought I can't say that because I don't
want to [ __ ] rush it because I don't
mess it up again they're very excited
about that's put me in a better mood you
know if they say you know hey at least
you got your health because it puts you
in a bad goddamn mood
alright so somebody was asking me Dean
Dell Rhea's diet hi Bill can you please
talk about Dean Dell Rhea's diet details
on on his next podcast I'd like to lose
a little weight myself so I have to go
into Dean Dell Rhea's podcast
let there be talk from the all things
comedy network network network Dean can
explain it I don't remember all of it I
just kind of like I eat like for
breakfast I have two eggs over AG and
then I have one serving of steel-cut
oats that take for [ __ ] ever to cook
it's another way to lose weight waiting
for your food to be ready and then for
like a snack I'll have a zekiel bread
which tastes like [ __ ] unless you put
butter and there's that and I have
almond peanut butter it's almond butter
is what it is and I have that and that's
actually [ __ ] delicious and it's
filling and then for lunch
I have quinoa
with with black beans and then I throw
salsa on top to give it some sort of
[ __ ] flavor because other than that
you know I've never eaten a shoe with
you know with a newspaper on top because
that's what it tastes like and I try to
avoid throwing salt learning that [ __ ]
in there and then in the afternoon I
don't know what the [ __ ] do I have
there's always at one meal before you
have the real meal right around four
o'clock I have like a [ __ ] I don't
know what sometimes I'll have whatever
the [ __ ] I want and other times is like
this pasta that's made out of chickpeas
it tastes a little weird but it's not
that bad you know and then for dinner I
just have a protein with like a salad
and I'm done and I just drink waters and
I stay away from the booze and all of
that [ __ ] and it's just weird thing
when you eat like that where I think
what you will you said oh my god this
food so boring and blah blah blah blah
blah it's because you're used to the
sugar or salt it gets your system going
like sugars like yeah our salt does
whatever the [ __ ] salt does like it's
like you get you fix so when you eat
that's what I eat stuff that doesn't
have any of that in it
you're just not hungry afterwards and
it's weird and then but you feel
energized but it's a it's a different
kind of you got to adjust your brain to
the fueling your body rush as opposed to
the the rollercoaster of sugar and salt
[Music]
so that that's as much as I I've been
doing that and then you know I eat like
that most of the time probably eighty
percent of time I eat that way and then
occasionally if I just want to have a
[ __ ] pizza I eat it but Dean doesn't
Dane just [ __ ] stays with it and that
[ __ ] guy everyone smile he sends me a
picture of him when I first met him it
doesn't he doesn't look at the same
person because not only did he lose all
this weight like he like his skin
[ __ ] cleared up you know
it used to look like a [ __ ] cop with
20 years in is what he used to look like
you know now he looks like a [ __ ]
rock star so I would listen to him on
his podcast let there be talk I'm sure
he said a dietitian of something he gets
great guests over there all right bill
you're not an addict hey old ginger
balls I'm a big fan of the podcast and
looking forward to your next special and
the new season of f is for family keep
up the great work thank you
I've been listening to the podcast for
the last couple weeks and I've heard you
going back and forth about abstaining
with from booze and most recently about
a a yeah I'm sorry I [ __ ] I said a lot
of bad things about a a if it [ __ ]
works when it works for you it's just
it's just fun to make fun of that [ __ ]
you know it's funny I sell your day in a
strip mall that was you know all these
different stores or one of the one of
the stores there it said Alcoholics
Anonymous you know I mean it's it's kind
of putting it out there isn't it you
know it's bad enough these poor people
had to sneak into porno stores and that
type of [ __ ] back when they were
drinking now you're not gonna do that to
him just shouldn't say bill dub use well
I guess you didn't have that signed up a
bunch of [ __ ] like me might be walking
in like what are you guys selling you
guys be like hope smoke-filled room with
doughnuts I've been working in addiction
I'm back to the letter I have been
working in addiction in the addiction
field for over a decade teach an
addiction course at a college and work
at one of the most highly respected
addiction programs up here in Canada ah
dude you know you had it all you ad me
think you said Canada Canada doesn't
count
dude you you live in Canada for me to be
considered an alcoholic in Canada if it
drink like [ __ ] two cases of molson
you guys are animals up there half you
guys don't know you're alcoholics you
just think you keeping warm
alright I mean let me not judge this guy
now that I've mentioned my credentials
while at the same time sounding like a
pompous [ __ ]
oh I love this guy called himself own I
can tell you that you are
not an addict it's like you are not the
father
you are not an addict where everything
you have mentioned on the podcast that I
am a longtime listener Oh see when you
say we listen the last couple of weeks I
guess you'd dip in and dip up right all
right the word addiction is thrown
around a lot so is the word here oh it's
thrown around a lot and typically refers
to any behavior that is out of our
control
to put it as simply as possible people
will often say things like they're
addicted to things like TV shopping sex
etc people also use the word to explain
withdrawal system symptoms of a
substance or behavior ie I must be
addicted to coffee because I get
headaches in the morning if I don't get
a cup however experiencing enjoyment or
withdrawal symptoms does not mean that
someone has an addiction we just kind of
stop here and say this is one of the
best written [ __ ] letters in a while
I apologize that my level of intellect
is reading it but I think you guys can
hear that this person seems to know what
he's talking about or she or it or her
who used to be him did I cover
everything however in the Edition in the
addiction field there is a way to tell
if someone has an addiction we call them
the four C's of addiction cash [ __ ]
cauliflower and I don't know I ran up in
the charges la charges okay if you have
persisted if you okay if you have
persistent cravings for drugs alcohol /
alcohol if you have lost control over
how much and how frequently you use if
you continue to use despite consequences
ie
legal issues job loss children take it
away and if you feel a compulsion to use
ie
always feeling like you need a drug or
alcohol as a bunch of weed smokers going
up alcohol is a drug then you can begin
to think you have an addiction knowing
what I know about from you on the
podcast I'm not going to pretend to know
you personally I have never heard you
mention any significant consequences
around booze other than your DUI when
you were young and you have control of
booze since you can have a full bar in
the house and not drink it and abstain
for long periods at a time from booze
the bar in the home also means you don't
have a compulsion to drink people that
struggle with significant alcoholism
cannot have booze just sitting around
their place drinking it it's [ __ ]
funny to me I don't know why I like to
just sitting there seen at the corner of
the ride they're like sweating
it's [ __ ] looking at me man you like
that black dude and predators shaving
your head over there on that bar
I don't believe you have an addiction
and you don't need to go to a a for me
he wrote it all in capitals you're just
some content likes to booze whose job
and lifestyle allows for it dude you're
gonna talk me into drinking tonight
now if you ever feel like you D do need
some serious help go see a professional
instead of some sorry sap bleeding his
heart out in a church basement in front
of a group of strangers having said that
I know he a does work for some people
and if you're into that knock yourself
out you just like me you had to [ __ ] on
it a little bit I hope this helps and
can silence the Bill W listeners of the
Monday morning podcast
best of luck in the new year and all the
best Ania and your lovely daughter and
go [ __ ] yourself Wow I might have to
[ __ ] download up download that
whatever print it out and frame it at
framers dotnet whatever the [ __ ] those
people are frame bridge I gotta use
those guys for that wow that was awesome
that made me feel better about myself am
I gonna drink now no I got to go do a
set to me all right chef not making
enough money that was really informative
by the way I definitely went through
periods where I was craving it you know
it didn't want to drink and I was just
like this is what I did Andy and I would
just go over and I just you know but I
felt more like a diet thing
like late at night just [ __ ] eat well
don't go out and go make a [ __ ]
grilled cheese sandwich your friend and
then you just go out and do it but want
that first [ __ ] night when you don't
do it then I can stop so yeah if I don't
think I am bill stop giving examples the
guy left you off the hook all right chef
not making enough money all right dear
Billy Betty Crocker I like that one way
to go champ
on your pie making skills I'm the chef
of a new restaurant
this year the restaurant has made a
hundred grand more than a year before
the restaurant is doing great but I'm
making sad money I have a wife and a
daughter my wife has always supported my
cooking but I don't make the money I
should recently my wife told me I could
work with her brother as an electrician
for the water district I could be making
three times more than what I could as a
chef I love cooking it's the one thing
that makes me happy do I hang tight with
the cooking and do what I love
or skip out and go with the easy money I
have investors ready to support my
cooking
but I need money now love to hear what
your thoughts are your thoughts out
Jesus dude this is a huge [ __ ]
decision how much do you love cooking is
this your dream is this what you want to
do I I can only equate the stand-up
comedy there is not a job out there that
would have paid three times more than
what I could make is a comedian that I
would have ever even for a second
considered ever ever not even for a
[ __ ] second okay if you feel that way
about cooking that I would stay with the
chef jump however if you know if you
don't feel that way then I would talk to
somebody else this is a major decision
to it I'm not making this decision for
you but I can tell you you know one of
the great things about my dream of being
a comedian was I really had no other
options because I kind of sucked at
everything else and I was miserable
doing anything else and that was the
only thing I ever did were
the second I did it I was just like oh
I'm doing this for [ __ ] ever I said I
don't give a [ __ ] so but I'd also didn't
have a wife and a daughter at the time
there's a lot of variables here you have
investors ready to support your cooking
but any money right now I would say this
if you this is your decision buddy if
you decide to keep cooking you got it
you got to get your wife on the right
page you guys gotta get on the unlike
say on the same page you know if you
really believe in yourself and then you
can run a restaurant you'd be one of
those guys right walking around with the
orange clogs [ __ ] riding a Vespa and
all that [ __ ] you know like Mario Batali
that was another guy Fergie grabbed a
couple people's asses now I never get to
see him again
you know I mean can he just [ __ ] from
his self-imposed exile he can't just
make a [ __ ] use the well method and
show me how to make something you know
you just put him on a leash right you
put him on a [ __ ] leash and he can't
go anywhere away from the island in his
kitchen
anyways all right that's what I would do
okay sir I would ask how much do you
want to be a [ __ ] chef alright if you
want to be a chef you got to get your
wife on the same page other than that
you know if it's not your [ __ ] dream
then you could just [ __ ] become an
electrician who has the best [ __ ]
cook outs ever all right ex-girlfriend
hooks up with stranger at Party we both
attended okay hey Billy on the back nine
of life that's true
my girlfriend and I broke up about four
months ago after an 11-year relationship
Wow sorry to hear that we share a lot of
the same friends and I knew we would see
each other at a friend's New Year's
party two days before the party my ex
hit me up and asked to get a drink and
clear the air before seeing each other
for the first time since the breakup we
had an awesome time and we ended up
going out again
the next night and had an even better
time she then asked if I wanted to share
a cab to and from the New Year's party I
agreed well at the party she met a guy
and they were all over each other the
entire night Oh God
she ended up ditching me and going home
with him at the end of the night I have
hooked up with a few people since the
break-up but never in front of my ex and
after the previous two nights I was
totally devastated by what she did I
would love any advice or insight Thanks
and go [ __ ] yourself well that it really
seemed like unless she was completely
shit-faced that really seemed a little
calculated and that right there sir your
story right there is why I avoided
staying in contact with ex-girlfriends
not saying they were all bad but I had a
girlfriend like that an ex and they have
like this sixth sense is right as you're
starting to get past and over them they
just feel it they call you up and they
just [ __ ] your life your head up all
over again here's one for you dude what
kind of a person would do that huh the
kind of person that you don't want to
put your seed in just know that that
could have been the mother of your
[ __ ] children you dodged a bullet
congratulations sir congratulations okay
and I'm willing to bet that unless she
completely [ __ ] up her life you will
not hear from her again or you will hear
from her because she is a sadistic
person and wants to hear your reaction
she wants to hear the pain and get off
on it while she goes like well I didn't
think there'd be a problem because we
were broken up so I don't know why
you're putting this on me okay I thought
we both had we have nice time we were
adults in the whole time she's just
getting off on the fact that you still
give a [ __ ]
so dude you dodged a major [ __ ]
bullet I mean I I would never do that to
somebody I would never I wouldn't do
that duck if you know I wouldn't do that
now I've been with Nia forever I've I
saw an ex girl I would never [ __ ] I
would just whisper hey let's get out of
here that's gonna you know let's go
someplace a little more quieter I would
never do that to somebody that's just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] male of female to do
that to somebody's a really [ __ ]
[ __ ] thing I'm sorry that happened to
you but you know what you know what's
great dude she's out of your life she's
out of your life it you know you know
what those people about they're like
those what about Bob people you know
remember the beginning of what about Bob
the therapist gets Bill Murray's
character away from him
dumps him in [ __ ] dreyfuses lap
that's what she's she's the [ __ ] the
female version those what about Bob
people if you can never dump him off on
other people it's [ __ ] tremendous and
she did it to herself this is what you
do anytime you ever see her after that
just big smile on your face big smile on
your face are you doing
are you mad nah no we've broken up good
for you you know have the time of your
life all right nice seeing you leave all
right and now's a great time dude to
[ __ ] expand your horizon find new
friends indulge in a [ __ ] hobby
travel get yourself in great shape go to
the gym it's time to [ __ ] work on you
and that person you this is in the
rearview [ __ ] mirror you know what
all she did was give you a great [ __ ]
story to tell the love of your life
because that that chick in it all right
enjoy your 2018 you're a free man
all right this girl is killing me man
all right dear Billy big head
oh [ __ ] you guys are really accurate
this week back nine big head I mean why
not when I'm [ __ ] on the ropes here
somebody throw in the towel I am a
sophomore in high school but I've been
listening to your podcast podcast for a
year now I need some advice out Jesus
Christ this is [ __ ] scary I hope you
need some [ __ ] regular advice alright
I need some advice on how to handle this
girl hey Nia you out there Nia you wanna
you want to give this kid some advice oh
[Music]
that's right you sick ok sorry hey let
me applause you alright I'm back I'm
back Jesus Christ she's still sick she's
still sick sleeping upstairs again
tonight alright some [ __ ] in high
school and I need some advice on how to
handle this girl I dated her for about
nine months last year a lot of heartache
dish this week and learned a lot the
problem is that this girl is really
immature and I cannot have a
conversation with her without her
arguing so I picked this up without
arguing with me or something over
something not important you're a son who
gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] move on to the next
one for example towards the end of my
relationship with her she gave me the
silent treatment from multiple days
because I told her I didn't like
Australia she constantly insulted me
called me dumb and told me I was a
terrible brother you datin your sister
or she just observed your family what
state did this come from
and did crazy things like this
throughout our relationship she's one of
those girls who thinks that she she's
always she oh that she always gets to be
right and I am NOT and I am not about
that life he says when she broke up with
me it was this whole scene well dude it
sounds like you dodged a bullet here
what dating is all about is meeting what
you don't want and then you figure that
out and then you finally [ __ ] meet
the
person you totally your [ __ ] youngest
[ __ ] what's the problem here I got very
close with their family and I'll see
your good guy and when we broke up her
seven-year-old sister sobbed Jesus
Christ her mom even went to the extent
to call me on the phone to tell me I was
a great boyfriend and wish me wish that
me and her could possibly work things
out in the future
her family adores me to this day due to
the fact that I really played up the
whole nice guy thing
what are you really an [ __ ] this is
where things get even worse she
constantly leads leads me on and I fall
for it yeah that's what being young is
all about and at a town fair we have we
have she hung out with me all weekend we
were very flirty and she heavily led me
on but when I asked her out she said she
wasn't ready all right dude
this once again if you listen to the
last so this is why you do not stay in
contact with ex-girlfriends okay
she just doesn't she doesn't want you to
meet someone else until she's met
somebody I don't know what why I don't
know what the [ __ ] they think I just
know I just know you just you gotta you
gotta you guess you gotta walk you gotta
walk all right the same thing happened a
few months later I have left her alone
for the past few months only talking to
her once every three weeks and every
time she ends up being mad at me for
some dumb reason an hour ago she was mad
at me for not roasting her and called me
pathetic roasting her I'm trying to
figure out where the [ __ ] you live you
got a little fare a town fair and then
you guys also have roasts I don't know
what this is all right she apologized
all the time for her action but
continues to do the same thing should I
not even talk to her or should I forgive
her because she's just immature and
can't handle our feelings any advice
would be appreciated especially to get
the the lovely Nia to answer as well I
hope the family's doing great and go
drink a beer
that's hilarious uh yeah I would just
have a conversation I would just say
listen I don't enjoy talking to you
because you always get mad and you yell
at me we are broken up and I don't think
it's healthy for us to continue talking
to one another however when I see you I
don't want it to be weird so is there a
way that could you you in a nice way
could just [ __ ] off and let me get on
with my life but if I see you you know
we could just walk by you know we could
raise eyebrows you know and acknowledge
that we saw each other maybe we could
high-five and not saying anything you
know and then if she flips out it gives
a [ __ ] the kids are [ __ ] mean it's
just doesn't you know doesn't sound like
he's a question for you is since you
broke up has it ever ended well any
interaction any interaction you've had
with her okay if the answer is no then
she got to stop interacting with it but
it seems like it's such a small town I'm
judging you because you went to a fair
okay so my world you brought your prize
Pig down there and I don't what the [ __ ]
happened after that
all right I would say yeah I would just
you know this I imagine plenty of other
women you uh you know what's the proper
word at that is chicks you [ __ ] go to
school with there's really no middle
world right girls you're not girl at
that point you're [ __ ] teenager I
don't I'm not going on Wikipedia again I
don't know what the [ __ ] word is okay
there's plenty of the [ __ ] chicks you
could be hanging out with alright that's
it and here's the thing here's a tip for
you when you [ __ ] hang out with them
don't talk about your old relationship
what about some other [ __ ] woman they
know what they want you they don't want
to hear it just go have a beer with one
of your buddies out in the woods however
[ __ ] you do it just be like yeah you
know I I don't encourage underage
drinking whatever the [ __ ] it is you
guys do that's when you vent
what do you what you have to do is every
time it starts to scab over she calls up
or you call her and then you got an open
wound again what you got to do is you
got it you got a heal like a [ __ ]
x-man and then the next time you see her
and I guarantee if you don't give a [ __ ]
she's gonna [ __ ] be all over you and
want to hook up and this is what you
have to do you got
not do it and then watch how quickly or
that all that flirty turns into [ __ ]
anger and then she's gonna yell at you
and then just be keep you cool be like
this is why I don't hang out with you
cause y'all [ __ ] crazy
something like that and I would also ask
some more adults who actually actually
know the people involved in this story
including yourself okay alright good
luck to you alright sister is obese
alright sister is obese dear freckles
hoping you can offer some advice my
sister is and has always been on the
heavy side now that sucks but [ __ ] has
gotten out of hand if I had to guess her
body fat is easily 40 to 50 percent I
love her and I'm struggling to get
through to her you seem like you never
hold back or sugarcoat reality should I
do the same in this situation I don't
want to send the poor girl into a
whirlwind of emotions and maybe that's
what but maybe that's what she needs
thanks for the help
well that's a big one dude I don't know
how old she is I don't know I don't know
her yeah how do you get somebody how do
you tell somebody tell your sister she's
fat let's let me just improv a couple
scenarios here hey sis how you doing
did I mention you're overweight that's
too blunt what has four limbs and needs
to lose 85 it's not good to joke about I
don't know how you do it cuz I don't
know how fragile she is and I wouldn't
want her to go more in that direction
because nobody wants to is there a way
that you can just start cooking a little
more healthy around the house and
inducer or to some stuff or maybe get
her to start working out with you maybe
just go for a walk or something like
that
maybe he just sit down he have a great
talk with her and find out what's going
on with her and you don't bring up her
weight maybe you work on your
relationship with her and then she opens
up and maybe there's some sort of pain
that's causing her to eat like that I
mean that's like a psychological thing
sometimes from what I've heard Mon shows
that I've seen where people actually
know what they're talking about so maybe
you need to get like I don't what your
relationship is but maybe if she feels
comfortable opening up to you just ask
her what's going on with her how she
doing how's she feeling
bla bla bla bla bla and if she you know
there's something going on with her
maybe she lets that out and then maybe
she brings it up and I hate how I look
and you could be like well let's do
something about it you don't maybe try
what try that way but I don't think I
would bring up that she's fat I wouldn't
do that as much as I made those jokes
but this podcast is supposed to be funny
and it's supposed to be [ __ ]
ridiculous so I had to do a couple all
right well you want for me I'm bald with
the big head and I'm on the other side
of the [ __ ] golf course
it's it's it's what I meant all right
that's the podcast people if you enjoyed
this podcast you'd like to donate but
not without spending a [ __ ] dime just
go to my website bill burr com click on
the podcast page and just click on the
amazon link go on Amazon and buy
something you don't really [ __ ] need
it's not gonna cost you any money and
I'll get a little bit of credit for
driving traffic their way and they'll be
like God bill is a couple of bucks
that's it
all right everybody I'm gonna go drink
my face off because I'm not an alcoholic
now I'm gonna go do a set I'm gonna go
do a set cuz I'm gonna be at Cobbs
comedy club next say night after I do
Kevin Pollak show he's got to be
interviewing me or whatever so it's
gonna be fun I love that guy so I'd do
anything for him including going up to
San Francisco to hang out with them
doing a show alright that's it everybody
belching here I'll check in on you on
Thursday go [ __ ] yourselves and have a
wonderful couple of days